all right welcome back to what's it
Wednesday unless of course this is your
first time at what's it Wednesday in
which case welcome for the first time -
what's it Wednesday before I reveal what
this skull was from last week I want to
take a quick break to talk about two
weeks ago as you may or may not remember
I was on vacation last week and so I had
to pre-record things and I was not able
to actually congratulate the winners
from two weeks ago that was the episode
on the turkey vulture and the winner for
that according to my count was YouTube
user Tyranno
one so congratulations my friend you
were right on the Internet as for your
question
shoot I'm gonna say your name wrong and
I apologize but as for your question
Rishabh Bharadwaj no I did not get the
link that you sent me if you sent it to
me in the YouTube comments
it's hard for me to find because I have
two YouTube channels so I don't actually
get a chance to read them all but just
so that you and everybody else in the
world watching this knows if you want to
get a hold of me get a hold of me on
Twitter if you just tagged me in a post
on Twitter I am pretty much guaranteed
to see it my Twitter handle is at stated
clearly that's at stated clearly and by
the way stated clearly is my main
youtube channel if you don't already
follow me over there anyways one last
bit of news before we reveal what
species this skull was I feel this
strange need to just kind of casually
mention YouTube user jive Dodson and
Steven Baumann I don't know why I just
want to casually mention you there you
go glad to know that you're playing and
enjoying this game without further ado
this skull is a coyote skull so
congratulations to all you smartypants
out there a lot of you said it was a dog
that's close it's kind of true ish I
mean coyotes can breed with dogs it's
fairly rare because their sexual cycles
don't usually align but it does happen
you can get coyote dogs hydrogen get
coyote wolf hybrids in fact the red wolf
I'm not totally sure on their entire
range but we had red wolves in Tennessee
and the red wolf
Ellard in Tennessee for three years the
red wolf is actually we think a hybrid
between the gray wolf and the coyote and
it's a really fascinating case where
usually the hybrids between wolves and
coyotes they're just kind of mixed up
there their instincts are weird they
behave strange they usually don't do
well but this is something that we call
out breeding depression when two
different species are close enough to
mate and do mate but oftentimes the the
hybrids aren't very good at surviving we
call that out breeding depression it's
the opposite of inbreeding depression
which is a few you know mate with your
cousin or whatever the red wolf is a
really interesting case because there is
an out reading event or a crossbreeding
event and then the offspring then
re-crossed with either the wolf or the
coyote and that happened multiple times
until natural selection was able to sort
out the best traits of both species and
kind of breed them into one and we get
the red wolf so it really should be
considered its own species some people
debate whether or not should be
protected because it's a hybrid I say of
course it should be protected it is if
you don't want to consider a unique
species it's at least a very specific
unique ecotype an eco type is a
population of animals that have adapted
to survive in a very specific ecosystem
and it definitely is a noteworthy
ecotype there the red wolf but anyway
this was a coyote congratulations to all
of you who guessed that correctly
moving on this week's guest is another
bird as you probably figured immediately
what could this thing be this is another
bird with a very unusually large brain
case for its size and yeah that's my
thumb so you can kind of get this is
about what 2 inches maybe two and a half
inches long this
skull oh my gosh such a cool animal I
love these guys a lot of people hate
them I love these birds I love them I
feed them I make the neighbors upset by
attracting them to the property oh yeah
these things are awesome
native to Oregon well I mean when I say
native I mean they've been here way
longer than Oregonians have beautiful
animal absolutely gorgeous I love these
guys what is it
what's it Wednesday let me know what you
think this says in the comment section
it's a fairly easy one I must admit
I'm excited to see what your guesses are
sadly I cannot open the mouth because
it's glued shut this comes from Shin
Timoney Wildlife Center
look at those big feet
you